the fate of the universe lies in your
shoulders now whatever you do don't push
this but cuz that will set off the bomb
immediately and we'll all be dead
now repeat back what I just said
conquer it no that's the button it will
kill everyone try again
conquer mm-hmm okay uh-huh
No Showtime a-holes up
[Music]
you face
does anybody have any tape out there I
want to put some tape over the dead [__]
nobody has any tape not a single person
has hey you have an atomic bomb in your
bag if anybody's gonna have taken to you
I have to do after you are wasting a lot
[Applause]
that's a really bad sign
if I touch someone I can feel their
feelings your feel yeah yeah I guess
yeah I feel a general unselfish love for
just murder no sexual no no I don't for
ha no ha ha ha
see you stole everyone your deepest
darkest secret dude come on I think
you're overreacting alone you must be so
embarrassed
ha ha ha ha ha
[Music]
Oh
when you hop
and your arms so don't let me go
there are two types of things in the
universe
those who dance those who do not
I get it yes I am a dancer Kimora is not
you just need to find a woman who is
pathetic like you thanks boy do you need
a hug no no I do not
oh my god I said you're welcome
I'm high on the lead